oh my god this is going on facebook  smile  [Music]  look at you still i'm muscly and  everything  how's space this place is fine  [Music]  whoa does he need cpr because i totally  know cpr  [Music]  is there somewhere a lady could get a  cup of coffee  you guys look like you might get down  with those little pod things  horrendous for the environment  so i show up to work at the lab slash  your mom's house  fully expecting you to be roping around  your pajamas eating ice cream and  obsessing about  you know who but you're not you're  wearing lady clothes  moving shower didn't you smell good  i'll tell you everything you wish to  know everything yes  all the answers you seek will be yours  once i reclaim your name  what's miami  lewis dr lewis  [Music]  you